some video games are fun from start to
finish
others seem to leave out the finish part
and remain unbeatable forever here's a
selection of games that for whatever
reason haven't been beaten by very many
people maybe you'd like to try
Battletoads its difficulty is the stuff
of myth many claim to have beaten
Battletoads without having any actual
proof The Adventures of rash zits and
pimples each a you had to battle
multiple streams of bad guys and you
could accidentally punch your own
teammate
it was completely possible to keep dying
because of friendly attacks harsh
takeshi's challenge
takeshi's challenge gave fit to Japanese
Famicom fans the Takeshi in question is
actor director Takeshi Kitano
a man who holds the distinction of being
one of the first celebrities to get
involved with the world of gaming sadly
his efforts produced what is widely
considered to be one of the worst games
of all time takeshi's challenges nearly
unbeatable largely because of gameplay
that pretty much depends on trial and
error there's even one section that
requires the use of the second
controller's microphone to sing karaoke
while the game could be beaten by
suffering through the confusing gameplay
you could also have thrown thirty
thousand seven hundred and twenty
punches on the opening screen to get to
the ending say goodbye to your thumbs
and maybe you're on Super Meat Boy
released in 2010 Super Meat Boy was
created as an intentional throwback to
the crazy hard games of our use and if
you ask anyone who's played it it
definitely delivers on that promise
there are tons of videos on YouTube that
show players dying over and over and
over again
needless to say Super Meat Boy is one of
the hardest games released in recent
memory and fans love it for that very
reason and while there are plenty of
players that soldiered through the
challenge of beating the game steams
global gameplay stats lissa measly two
percent of players achieved 100%
completion on it maybe they should
rename this game to Super incomplete boy
Friday the 13th
as we mentioned Super Meat Boy is an
homage to the type challenging games of
yesteryear but for every Metro Raiders
Super Mario Brothers there's lots of
other old games that were hard not
because they were good but because they
were bad very very bad
case in point Friday the 13th for the
original Nintendo Entertainment System
in 2009 Game Informer magazine included
this on its list of the worst horror
video games other magazines have gone a
step further by calling Friday the 13th
the worst games ever made period Friday
the 13th is very nearly impossible to
beat but mostly because it's so crappy
that most players would simply throw
their controllers to the TV before
getting anywhere close to completing it
that still counts right Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Konami's Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles game deserves a special
place on our list despite the fact that
it gave players bald spots from tearing
their hair out in frustration it was
actually very popular at the time
because of impossible experiences of the
ones provided by Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles we can finally look back at a
time when games not only challenged us
but also extinguish our hope of
finishing them call it a sneak peek at
the harsh realities of adult life thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which game you think is
unbeatable
you